hello, how are you, hector mejía greets you with
his brief information for today, thursday
, april 8, a substitute teacher from
the clark county school district
is under arrest after being accused
of luring minors to have
sex virtually the
police department again las  vegas arrested erc
and wii on march 3 the
arrest report indicates that he offered a sum
of 100 dollars to have sex with a
virtual person who he thought
was over 15 years old but this turned out to
be an undercover police officer
hewitt  he was a substitute teacher of
english in high school to western for
a long time anyone who
has been a victim please
contact the authorities
and more tourists come to las vegas'
which means more hotels need
employees sisters in the film looking to
hire  two hundred waitresses the
company will do zoom interviews today
from nine in the morning to two in the afternoon
you must fill out an application prior to this
good luck
in the meantime las vegas' record
starts full time
starting today the hotel and casino was
only operating half a week since october due to
the crisis generated by the pandemic but
now it will be open seven days a
week
and now we pass  to the weather forecast
we will have a hot and sunny day for
today with temperatures 10 degrees
above normal hovering around 80
I have a nice mejía selector newspaper and
this was their brief Spanish edition news